so one of the things that we have really
defined as a part of this entire study
is that a personal brand is not about
what you do
it is about who you are like i want to
see what it's like to be the mom or the
dad or the husband or the wife or the
friend it's like i want to see you
cooking spaghetti not just
flashing your private jet in your fancy
car and talking about your course all
the time it's like i want to see the
humanity component of who you are
because that is equally as important
in this decision to me
than just what you do
welcome back to the think media podcast
sean cannell here and i'm excited for
today's topic all about personal
branding and a groundbreaking new study
that actually reveals some actual data
and insights of why personal branding
matters why it'll lead to more revenue
more trust more growth for your social
media platforms your business and your
brand and impact overall and my guest
today is aj vaden now if you're just
meeting her she's the ceo and co-founder
of brand builders group and one of the
world's leading experts in personal
brand strategy and over the last 15
years she's helped launch and
start multiple seven and eight figure
businesses along with her company brand
builders group aj has also been featured
in success magazine inc fast company
entrepreneur and good morning america
and this study actually revealed some
super powerful things that we're going
to be unpacking today so buckle your
seatbelt because there's a lot of value
coming up but aj welcome to the podcast
yeah so happy to be here i got lots of
things to share so we're going to have
to cram it all in
so i'm super pumped to dive into it i
want to just kind of uh read some things
and i've already been looking at the
study it's super exciting and one of the
things that uh
is true about the study and of course
you'll break it down but this is also
this is a next level validated data
weighted u.s census that revealed 74 of
americans are more likely to trust
someone who has an established personal
brand 67 percent of americans are
willing to spend more money on products
and services from companies of founders
whose personal brands align with their
own values and even for bigger companies
that are maybe you know our audience is
a lot of youtube creators and and really
like author speaker
content creator personal brands even big
corporations are really benefiting from
personal branding and so before we dive
into some of your insights and the
things that surprise you from this study
what is your definition of personal
branding yes well i'm going to give you
a two-part answer to that question uh
because there's my opinion and what our
company brain builders group defines as
a personal brand but then we also asked
that exact same question to our audience
it was over a thousand americans who
participated in the six-month process of
gathering all of this research but i
would say that a personal brand
simply
is the
digitization
and or the monetization of your
reputation and i really do believe that
personal brand and reputation are
synonymous they're not all that
different it's just a personal brand as
a more proactive intentional approach of
expanding your reputation whereas the
reputation that you have is the more
reactive it just is what it is
it's by default whereas a personal brand
is that proactive effort of saying this
is what i want to be known for so i'm
going to be known for that but it truly
is just a formalization of your
reputation in a proactive manner now
that's how we would define it um but we
asked the exact same question uh in our
study which is what is a personal brand
and this was really interesting because
a ton of people came back and said it's
uh content creators uh most of the
people we said we asked that uh they're
professional service people which was
not even on our radar but at the end of
the day if you kind of like consolidate
all these different things that
americans said
i think the easiest way to define a
personal brand for americans today is
it's simply someone who is recognizable
that's it
not famous not
an influencer and i use the bunny ears
there on purpose but it's someone who is
simply recognizable so that could be in
your industry in your own company in
your local area but it's just someone
that is well known
and i love as we unpack this and and
dive into the insights of the study as
well as tips for building our personal
brands i love that you said you know and
essentially this could either happen by
accident because we're all going to
build a reputation regardless or we
could be intentional or also if we're
not intentional we may not end up
getting known especially as it pertains
to growing our businesses into the
future of this next decade i mean i'm so
passionate about personal branding but
let's just i mean you're here uh with
this brand new study there's so much
impact what are some of the insights and
data that surprised you yeah so there
are several things that i think are
really really significant for the way
that we do business today and uh since
we're in the business of personal
branding we talk with people all the
time about what is a brand and do you
need one and how do you get one but
here's the thing that we get hit up with
all the time is that people naturally
assume that somehow personal branding is
directly correlated to social media
and that's just not true social media is
a part of how people hear about you and
learn about you and learn from you but
that actually has nothing to do with
your actual personal brand and so what
we have seen is that for quite a while
people have seen it as more of this
thing that you do if you're an online
influencer or it's a vanity project and
what we're seeing now specifically with
gen z who is age 18 to 25 the emerging
workforce it's no longer a thing of
popularity and vanity but they actually
declare it a critical and essential part
of doing business and how they make
decisions
and i think that's the turn of events
here because personal branding has
really gone from this thing that maybe
authors and speakers and podcasters do
to become more well known to know this
is a critical and necessary part of
doing business today and some of the
statistics that you shared are also ones
that we find that are really important
like 67
of americans say they are willing to
spend more money not just money but more
money from companies whose founders have
personal brands that align with their
own personal values so i'm going to kind
of stop there for a second because we
did so many case studies on this very
particular topic because we're talking
about more than two-thirds of americans
are going this is no longer about some
company or entity or organization who's
just selling me stuff anymore it's due
to a variety of reasons that i'm sure we
could go down a deep deep dark rabbit
hole on that we don't need to go down
people want to know who is behind this
company
i want to know what their missions and
values are and if i like them and i
align with them i will buy from you be
loyal to you and spend more money with
you because of the person not the
company
these are uh you've already done a fire
hose of insights here but you know i'm a
small town kid and uh grew up on a farm
six acres in arlington washington and
it's funny because you know personal
branding like you said probably gets
stereotyped or does get stereotyped and
oh it's influencers um oh it's vanity or
it's about fame and you're saying no
it's actually essential it's the
digitization of your reputation which i
think actually everybody listening from
any generation can relate to because
whether it's a small town that you grew
up in everyone there was different
characters that had a reputation in that
town maybe it was the reputation of the
guy that kind of always woke up late and
showed up to football practice with kind
of some like alcohol in his breath my
experience uh whether it was the guy you
know oh he's uh he's always got his
bluetooth earbud in he's he's a
contractor general you know and and
people know your name in the city they
maybe know what you do they know where
you work you start it's kind of small
town rules well now that's been
amplified by the internet
and it is be it's an essential component
of trust and doing business i i think
about how important this is i'm a
millennial but for me making decisions
someone was trying to sell me solar
panels the other day and after an
hour-long presentation at the house i
was very convinced but i'll tell you
what i began i became extremely
skeptical when i actually started
looking into this company's personal
brand specifically their social media
because those were my entry points i was
looking at their instagram i'm like why
is this kind of sketch and low quality
and not really not communicating much
who's really behind this company why is
there such little internet presence why
is the quality of their internet
presence so low i don't know if i want
to make a 65 000
financed solar panel decision with this
company and what's interesting is i
actually was convinced by the
presentation that i wanted to do solar
panels but then they lost my trust
because of essentially the personal bra
i i don't really know where the values
of the company were and some of those
points could have been the difference or
certainly would have been the difference
between me signing up and doing business
right there or not doing it which was
the case and i passed on the opportunity
to later probably end up getting solar
panels from costco yeah that's
interesting you said two things there
that actually were a part of our study
that we said were equally as important
and 69 of older millennials and i have
to pause because if you go and like
actually download this entire study we
split the millennial age group into
older millennials which are 36 to 44 and
then younger millennials which are
really 26 to 33 on purpose because it's
a vastly different
uh i would just say a
socioeconomic psychographic status in
this older millennial younger millennial
but older millennials 69
of them said they will check out the
online personal brand before they make a
purchase decision
and i just want to pause about that
because i know so many people and we'll
just pick on
professional services just for a second
um because
we're in professional services so i can
pick on us for a moment but how many
cpas doctors dentists lawyers
just think that's not what they need
like i you know it's like i've built my
business on word of mouth and referrals
and we're saying no you did that with
the baby boomers and maybe gen x but if
you want to stay in business
the future of business you need to have
an online established personal brand
because people no longer want to buy
just products and services they expect
for you to educate them
they want to learn from you before they
buy from you
and i think that's a really huge
clarifying point of the importance of a
personal brand in general is that if
you're just
selling products and services this
emerging consumer buying power in the
united states with millennials which we
already own it but then with gen z
they're going no i don't want to buy
from a company who just sells products
and services i want to be able to be
educated and informed and i want you to
teach me stuff before i buy from you
and most of the time that's going to
happen online
and i think that's really important but
then on top of that we even said when
when making a purchase decision today
what are the most important factors that
you look for
before you do that right so what are the
most important decisions
that factor into who you spend money
with and there were tons of them now
this is in the context of a personal
brand but we said is it important to
have a book and does that book need to
be a best-selling book or a new york
times best-selling book do you need a
podcast what about viral ted talks uh
consulting speaking training there was a
whole long list of things
this
blew
my mind
because i was certain i was absolutely
certain that having a new york times
best-selling book or being a top 50
ranked podcast or having a viral ted
talk would be somewhere near the top of
the list
nope
and let me tell you what this was so
fascinating to me um this was number 10
on the list and there were four things
that tied for equal number 10 and
americans said that having a blog yes a
blog
a self-published book
a traditionally published book or a new
york times best-selling book
carried the exact same weight
and how they made purchase decisions
i just want you to let that sink in for
a second
a blog which takes me approximately five
to seven minutes to put online with no
thought or research or a new york times
best-selling book that you will spend
years
and thousands and tens of thousands of
dollars writing editing promoting
publishing
have the exact same importance level
but then
let me tell you what they said was the
most important thing and these were the
three most important things by far and
far and away from everything else the
number one most important thing that
americans said that they want to see
about you in order for them to buy from
you is they want to see third-party
testimonials
online
what
that's like the cheapest fastest easiest
thing that we can be doing but they say
i want to hear what other people just
like me had to say about working with
you i don't really care if you have a
viral ted talk i don't really care if
you're a top host i don't care about all
the other stuff but what did other
people say that was the first thing the
second thing is i want to know if you
actually get paid by other people
to speak and consult on this topic and
then the third thing
is that you have a nice website those
are the top three things
man this is uh pretty powerful and that
quote you said
people want to learn from you before
they buy from you you know we really
help people build their influence on
youtube um 65 of people google review
revealed go to youtube trying to solve a
problem they have a pain point they want
to answer a specific question
you can create content to get in front
of those questions and help people
people want to learn from you first
before they want to buy from you but now
we can power up our personal brands by
maybe they're doing research they want
to hire us for our client services our
professional services
our coaching maybe an online course
maybe book sales is the goal or to get
hired to speak
how's your website doing think media
podcast how uh have you got some video
testimonials some written testimonials
and i like
aj go into
they want to know that people hire you
to speak so therefore
we should
probably spend at least some time maybe
trying to get on some stages would you
say in our industry uh at niche events
related to our industry unpack that
point a little bit yes and i think a lot
of this comes from perceived credibility
right and a part of building an
established personal brand is that you
are credible in your marketplace and
that could be industry or
location
uh but you're you're seeing is credible
and so that could be at trade shows that
could be at conferences that could be at
public seminars those could be on online
webinars that you even host for yourself
but then you offer those as master
classes to other organizations but what
people are saying is that if other
people are willing to pay for you to
talk and consult on this it gives me
more confidence thus more credibility
and trust that you're you know what
you're doing
it's this perceived expertise that's
really important and a lot of that too
is connected to the third party
testimonials they wouldn't they want to
know that other people
do this and other people are willing to
pay for it before they do
man so
personal branding is the future
especially if you want to not just be in
business today but in business tomorrow
you got to be thinking about being
intentional with your personal brand
personal branding is highly profitable
and when we
have built a strong personal brand
viewers
the study that studied people here in
america are willing to spend more so we
also can charge higher prices not a race
to the bottom with our products and
services but actually we weekends being
more premium because of that perceived
value and because of that personal brand
and also personal branding is a trust
accelerator and this is the digitization
as you said because now business is
being done online but people do business
the rules have not really changed people
do business with people they know like
and trust and so how do we accelerate
trust the answer is personal branding
what other insights do we need to know
that this study unpacked yeah so this is
like a three-part
uh piece of information i think is
really important so 67
right of americans say they're more
likely to buy from you if you have an
established personal brand but then we
kind of said okay well if that's
generally speaking does this get
differentiated if we segment the
industries and so we were super curious
to go well does this mean more or matter
more based on the type of industry that
you're in and americans through this
study said that they saw the most value
in professional services
and having a personal brand now that is
important to break down because this was
not what we expected
we thought it would be consultants and
trainers and coaches
at nope nope it was professional
services and so as we dug into that a
little bit more we said well what
what about professional services exactly
why is this such a correlation to have
an established personal brand
and us being willing to trust you buy
from you recommend you and so then we
said well which ones like help us
understand and the three most important
out of all of the ones that we asked for
and it was dozens of industries uh or
professions but it was doctors
lawyers
and employers
so the person who pays your check
your doctor
and
your
lawyer i just want you to pause about
that because i'm gonna i'm gonna talk to
you about our you know our hypothesis
around this from this data and if you
just sit there and you think about it
for a second and you go okay let's hold
up just for a moment because we're on
this topic of trust acceleration and
that's really where this you know key
finding came from is we're going
actually
the connectedness between having an
established personal brand and trust
are directly connected with someone's
ability to see you
know you
align with you learn from you way before
they buy from you and then the reason
this was so high for doctors and lawyers
and employers were for these three
reasons
and it's you better trust your doctor
because your life is in their hands and
you better trust your employer because
your livelihood is in their hands and
yes you need to trust your lawyer
because your freedom is in their hands
and so what we really saw is that the
higher
the level of trust that's required the
more established your personal brand has
to become
and that is really what we're sitting
with here it's going it's what are you
sharing
to allow people to go you know what
you're talking about
and so thus i can trust you and i will
buy from you and so doctors lawyers and
employers and then financial services
your financial advisor was right
underneath that but this was not at all
what we thought when we started out with
the study
we thought it was going to be very much
this culture trainer consultant market
and it was like far down the list
and it was the more everyday professions
of going no i need my doctor to be
putting out content and educating me so
i know i so i know if this is what i
believe in and this is what i align with
and the same thing i am customer
employee retention and employee loyalty
directly connected to their alignment
with the founder not the company
and so to break this down just one more
piece uh this was not from our study but
it's a connected piece of the study this
study was done by source trends but
source trends actually reports that 95
95
of a millennials say that their most
credible
source of product information
are their friends now that is
fascinating and terrifying at the exact
same time because i want you to think
about like your group of your like 10
closest friends and we're going these
are the most credible people who are
influencing our purchase decisions
and it's absurd
until you go but wait
these are the people that you know like
and trust
they're your friends
wow
and you know this next decade we've been
saying it's going to be the best decade
in the crater economy in youtube that's
what the data supports and what's
interesting is you know especially doing
business online
product purchasing online purchase
decisions online
um e-commerce is still less than 20 by
2022 it's not even supposed to be 20
it's shocking because i always ask
people how many percentage of people do
you think are shopping online versus in
physical stores that people say 9 out of
10 75 65 percent because they go i buy
everything online aj you probably you
probably have amazon boxes coming to
your house
every day rory's got book five books on
the porch probably every day that's just
like me and so stuff's like continuing
but but across america that is not
necessarily the reality we're if you're
listening to this podcast you're
probably in a very forward thinking kind
of a progressive mindset in terms of
that what does that mean though that as
more people start to come online as more
people are looking for data people they
can trust to give them quality
information about
products they want to purchase you know
the way i originally built uh financial
freedom was i built a six-figure income
reviewing tech on youtube and so i want
our community to hear like this is so
real
and your positioning of a powerful
personal brand and building up that
trust
is the unlock to you really being
financially successful in this next
decade i really believe that that if you
actually are having trouble with course
sales uh with your even youtube videos
converting with whatever's converting it
might not be a strategy tactics
problem it might not be a click-through
rate on your thumbnail problem sure you
need to get more viewership but the
trouble really could be is it might be a
trust problem what are you doing
intentionally to build a strong personal
brand to communicate your values to
build a bond because to the degree that
people trust you
personal branding those with that strong
trust factor they're willing to spend
more money on products and services and
they're also just looking for someone
they can they may not trust the brand
website they may not trust
even reviews or whatever it is they're
looking for quote unquote the
influencers the youtuber the instagram
person who they can learn from first and
then potentially buy from that's not
just your products that could be
affiliate marketing that you're doing aj
what do you think yeah i think it's
really important and there is something
that you said in there that made me
think about one of the data points that
we dug into that i think is really
relevant to this conversation and is
that a 53 percent of millennials say
that individuals who promote content and
ideas
are more influential in purchase
decisions than those who just promote
products and services and so i just want
to pause about that for a second and i
would really
i would like to say that i think most
people's biggest problems online
is that they don't let people know
enough about who they are and they all
they do is talk about what they do and
so one of the things that we have really
defined as a part of this entire study
is that a personal brand is not about
what you do it is about who you are as a
human being and so often i think we get
stuck in okay i've got to be like
talking content-wise only about these
products and services that i'm connected
to and what americans are saying it's
like no i also want to see your humanity
like i want to see what it's like to be
the mom or the dad or the husband or the
wife or the friend it's like i want to
see you cooking spaghetti not just
flashing your private jet in your fancy
car and talking about your course all
the time it's like i want to see the
humanity component of who you are
because that is equally as important
in this decision to me
than just what you do
and so it's how are we combining both of
those things
into
helping people fall in love with who we
are not just the stuff that we do
that's incredibly powerful i also think
that those who have
because there's so many different
monetization methods and and you teach
that in all your training too you find
the best vehicles the paids and if you
have it checked out we have a past
episode a couple past episodes with uh
aj's husband rory vaden aj's
yeah husband rory rory vaden uh on
personal branding in our title formulas
episode so definitely make sure to check
that out in the description down below
but when you're diving into the paids i
think about those who build a real
movement they build a real superfan fan
base and maybe their method of earning
money income is is maybe merch it's
people who really want to know and
support and wear their logo that doesn't
happen just by accident it's not really
just graphic design ability that is
where that magic is unlocked it's
exactly what you said people are buying
into the person they're having that
affinity to the person
and it's not just what they do but it's
also who they are and we're talking
values here and one of the things that
you guys uh have is the brand dna helix
um and uh in just a second we're gonna
get into some more tips but a couple of
things that you need to know first you
got to download this study and so we'll
put a link to this study that's in the
description or you can check out on the
podcast show notes on whatever platform
that you're uh listening really unpack
it because we can only really scratch
the surface with the insights that will
help you
powerfully position and build your
personal brand so get that and then also
um if you actually are interested in a
free strategy call
for building and monetizing your
personal brand
you can connect with brand builders aj's
team and they will help you with an
assessment of where are you at now and
help guide you on how to stand out in a
crowded marketplace so if you're
interested in that that's at
freebrandcall.com forward slash
think
and uh of course we'll put that in the
show notes as well and tell you a little
bit more about that um later but um aj
help us
unpack our values and for those saying
you know i don't know i don't do i just
go into story time i mean if i want to
add value in a video do i just tell my
life story how can i incorporate who i
am more and what are maybe even some
tactics i could apply across social
media and in my youtube videos
to build that bridge and that bond in my
content yeah i think there's two quick
things there and then um you have to
remind me to come back to two case
studies i was like literally having to
hold myself back as you were talking um
because they're so relevant to this
conversation and they're in the studies
so if we don't get to them you'll get
them in the download but here are two
things and these are these are two
things that i think are really really
important it's and to some degree and
i'm going to say i'm not saying this is
black and white and go all in either way
but to some degree
pick some platforms of choice that are
more personally oriented versus more
businessy professionally oriented like
so for example like if you want to get
to know me aj baden the human being the
mom wife friend sister daughter
christian like whatever it's like you're
gonna learn about that on instagram i
post very little content in terms of our
business or personal branding or
anything like that on my instagram it is
a genuine lifestyle like this is me as a
person and so people know it's like if
they wanted just to get to know me and
my personal values and my personal
alignment like that's where they're
going to get it they also know that if
they want to learn content and ideas
about business entrepreneurship personal
branding the study they're going to get
that on linkedin
and so it's like i very much
intentionally created some division of
how i source my profiles to create this
opportunity for me to go all in on
business and then all in on personal to
create that more unique loyal following
and i've also found that most of my
people follow me on both because they
want both from me but some want more of
the business and less of the personal
and others are vice versa so it's choose
the platforms in which and that's just
looking at your data it's getting into
your data and going what posts get the
most engagement what's post gets the
most reach and on instagram i will post
something about this study and then i
will post a picture of me practicing
t-ball with my two toddlers and it's 100
times the engagement
and so you got to just know your
audience on each of these platforms
which means you got to be into the data
that's the first thing the second thing
with every single thing that you talk
about with your business you have to
train yourself to speak through the lens
of you as a person
before you do it as you as a business
and so one of the practices that we do
is that we have our avatar right like
this we have a very specific person of
we know in my case her name her age her
psychographics what her needs are her
wants her desires her limiting beliefs
where she lives what her economic status
is what kind of job she has i know who
my ideal client is
and before i start talking about our
business or doing a podcast interview
i've got her in mind
and it's like i'm speaking to this
person and i know this person because i
relate to him because that's who i used
to be
and so it's speaking from this personal
state of i know who this is because this
was me and then it's easier to talk
about my own failures and my own
shortcomings and my own successes it's
both i talk a ton about me as a working
mom
but that's not my identity that's just a
part of what i do like being a mom or
being a ceo is not who i am those are
titles and those are things that i do um
and so it's like how do you weave all of
these components in uh to be a part of
the business and being really clear on
what those missions and values are and
actually sharing those with the public
because it actually means something
and i think i'm going to share this
really quick i think elon musk is a
great example of this right and i'm not
going to say i am one way or the other
i'm just using this as a case study but
he's got a cult like following for
people are who are super innovative and
super
technology right and this is the power
of a personal brand at play when it
comes to connecting who you are with uh
in this case uh currencies
right and so if you guys are into you
know the cryptocurrency world
specifically bitcoin then you know there
are trends all over that literally
follow elon musk's tweets
and watch how the market goes up and
down up and down based on his tweets
right so in january of 2021 this year
he simply changed his twitter bio to
hashtag bitcoin
and simultaneously
in the next 24 hours the bitcoin price
increased 20
then just a few months later he shared
that tesla was not going to be accepting
bitcoin dropped 12
just 30 days later changed his tune
increased back up 11 percent
so it's watching someone who is got
these deep
personal values around technology and
innovation and uh the environment and
climate and all these things and people
are going i align with that so what he
does i'll do
so you've got personal brands that are
influencing purchase decisions you've
got other personal brands that are
influenced entire currencies
at a a huge macro level there and then i
don't know if anyone on uh your audience
base is a huge soccer player uh but i
would be remiss if i did not share this
story because i'm new to the world of
soccer but i attend a lot of peewee
soccer so i'm getting into it right now
a lot
but this is also a really good example
um to talk about like actual dollars and
cents not just followers and influence
but actual dollars and cents and so
uh earlier this year just
august i think so we're talking about
just like a couple of months ago lionel
messi leo messi right made this uh very
unexpected announcement that he was
leaving as the fcb barcelona soccer club
and he was going to be moving over to
psg paris saint-germain right i know i
also have to say i know just enough to
sound like i know what i'm talking about
here i do not know the world of soccer
so give me a little grace but this is a
really important story so i shall
continue um so once he made that
announcement first of all the huge thing
that was going on in the media are these
unprecedented uh salaries that he would
be receiving and he signed a deal with
41 million dollars a year
with a 30 million dollar signing bonus
that is unprecedented i've never heard
of never happened before ever for one
player and a club that isn't maybe quite
at the top of their game
and so then the question was
why would they do this
and will they get a return on their
investment
right now why they would do it is
actually simple in my opinion um because
if you just look at social stats leo
messi has 260
million followers on just instagram
do you know how much the psg club has
38 million and they gained 11 million
followers in the 24 hours after his
arrival to psg now that's just on an
influence base a follower base but in
that exact same 24 hours after messi
landed in paris and they had the jerseys
printed with messi on them
they sold
100
million
dollars
in merch and 24 hours at a 10 profit
margin and picked up 10 million dollars
in the first 24 hours in just merch sold
out people were waiting for out it was
like you know the new iphone came out
but it was a jersey and this is before
ticket sales this is before anything
else this is just merch because of one
person
not a team a person like they know that
people follow the players
as much if not more than they do teams
the loyalty is with the person not with
the club
wow
now
that's incredible case studies and i
want to kind of bring that now down to a
street level though especially for the
lister and myself that says okay well
i'm i'm not quite to 60 million
instagram followers uh you know yet
uh 100 million or whatever um i i don't
have necessarily created that fandom yet
and so kind of stepping into um how do
we
start leveling up our personal brand
what are some of the first steps and
actions and how do we maybe pull that
down because of course that's a it's a
perfect illustration of what we might
want to have happen on a smaller level
right um and and so what are some
practical first steps now to put this
information into practice um and maybe
some of the biggest mistakes we could be
making by not using social media at all
using social media wrong not having a
website i mean there's a lot obviously
uh people should definitely reach out to
you because this is a whole journey but
give us some first steps yes so i would
say the first step is and this is i
don't care if you have an established
personal brand or you don't even know
what one is even after this interview
the first thing is you have to know
what problem do you solve
like for the world for your audience for
one person but what problem
do you solve
and that is the first step and that's
the hardest step for most people because
what they talk about is all over the
place so no one knows what to go to you
for and they need to know what to go to
for they need to know what do i
associate sean with what do i associate
aj with like what are they going to be
able to help me with so what problem do
you solve
that's the first thing the second thing
is you got to know who you solve it for
and that should dictate what you post
about but post about where you post how
you post how often you post those are
all the things are really important is
you really have to be tailoring it to
the person that you are speaking to the
person that you're solving this problem
for it's what do they need to know
and how do they need to hear it and
where do they need to hear it and you
know just data wise some of the data
points say that you know in the older
generations gen x and baby boomers 60
of the older generation say the
relevancy of the content to where i am
right now is the most important thing
with who they follow online
and it's relevancy of content so a part
of that is just going what's relevant to
my audience
and that's gotta you gotta get into the
psyche of the audience so a lot of this
data is interesting but how do you make
it applicable and a huge part of that is
knowing
who is my audience and where are they
online and it's appealing to them there
now for younger generations it was
similar but different in the fact they
said that uh 42 of the younger
generations gen z and millennials said
that
personality driven content was the most
important thing to them
so for the older generations it was more
about how do i take this content and
apply it to something that is relevant
in my business or in my life whereas the
younger generations are going i want
personality driven content i want to be
following people that i like and align
with and that could be entertaining or
informational but it's personality
driven and so if you just take those two
things and go okay if i don't know
anything else about my audience other
than roughly how old i think they are
these two things alone will really help
you because one is very much about give
me relevant information to improve my
life and my business right now and then
you gotta ask yourself well what are
those specifics
and now if it's a younger generation
demographic you've got to be going all
right they want personality driven
content which means they want more of me
sharing real life experience and
expertise not theory but real life
mistakes real life wins
and you've got to weave that into this
now i think this is also important
because i share these big case studies
that people who have huge followings
because you see what massive reach can
do
but at the same time the least the least
important thing to every single
generation was the number of followers
that you have
it does not matter if you have one or
100 million
that had the least amount of things to
do with deciding who i follow listen to
learn from engage with it was the least
important thing
and the most important thing was
relevancy of content that was solving
their problems and meeting them right
where they were yeah for the older
generations and then personality driven
content for the younger generations
wow so if i'm hearing you um
i gotta get really clear on i've got to
get clear on who i am
and self-awareness and my values
my mission my strengths because that's
going to identify
what problem do i solve and then i got
to get really clear on who
do i solve that problem for who is my
audience and if you're on the think
media podcast you've heard that before
but i want to challenge you to take a
breath
and and and and really assume that you
don't know number two i'll be honest
with you we're ten years into this we're
on our way past two million subscribers
um we're
building an eight-figure business and or
or have built an eight-figure business
and uh
we are asking that number two every day
and shocked and stunned by how little
we actually know of our audience now
clearly
we have uh made it where we are because
we've gone through the initial steps of
that but we're about to do an entire
audience survey we're realizing that
over time there can be almost like
mission drift or vision drift or
essentially alignment with your audience
drift just because you can become
out of touch have you ever thought about
that i used to like that person but um
they're kind of out of touch now so we
are aware that we're diving deep what
are our core audience avatars
psychographics what are they thinking
about what keeps them up at night what
are their problems what are their
ambitions and as far as some action
items on today's podcast
what uh
are the most relevant topics you could
be talking about you know on youtube
before you have a good title or a good
thumbnail or even good content you got
to be talking about the right topics you
got to be talking about the right things
and if you're talking about the things
that your audience and target viewer
cares about the most and adding value to
that that's going to be absolutely
uh powerful and you just gave us some
generational insights what generation
are we after maybe if we're trying to
reach everybody we might end up reaching
nobody but as far as a little bit older
generations the value piece the
relevancy younger generations are you
weaving enough personality into your
content maybe you have been so about
just business and adding value that you
haven't realized to build a bridge with
the next generation they need to know
what you care about they need to know
about your poodle they they want to know
you're into uh you know back to the
future or that you're into soccer or
those nuances you're a sports fan you're
a sci-fi
uh reader and and fantasy fiction reader
or whatever it is all these nuances and
bridge building things and so there's a
lot of details um that we could be
focusing on to level up our personal
brand aj i'm curious for you of course
freebrandcall.com forward slash think
because there's nothing more powerful
than people being able to get on the
phone with your team because it's really
this is so nuanced and so that
one-on-one coaching
think media podcast if you want to jump
on a on a discovery call use that link
and of course that's in the show notes
but aj if you were to give me literally
what should i do next i'm going to take
the next 30 minutes after listening to
this podcast and i'm going to do an
audit
uh especially maybe my online platforms
and here's here's the character i i am
pretty clear on the kind of content my
niche who i'm helping um and i am pretty
clear on what problem i solve i could be
a business owner or service provider i
already know i'm doing real estate i
already know i'm a cpa um i already have
a book written so i know the message i
want to get out to the world but i'm
staring at the internet wondering which
challenge i should target next is it a
website is it my social is it trying to
narrow down to one social platform
what are my next five moves okay well
i'm gonna start with your next two um
and then we can go from there um and i
think this is a really important thing
that sums up everything into one really
simple question is you have to be able
to answer this
what do i want to be known for
what do i want to be known for
and that can't be five things
so what do you want to be known for and
let that guide your next steps
and then the second more tactical thing
is if you were sitting here going all
right what is my next big move to become
more well-known well established grow my
business grow my customer base what our
data shows is that you need to get
yourself real busy real quick getting
client testimonials
that's what i would be doing i would
follow the actual data here of what
americans are actually saying that's
really important and it's going wow
when's the last time i actually asked my
clients to make me a video testimonial
or if those aren't very good maybe i
need to interview my clients maybe i
need to make some interview uh sales
videos maybe i need to weave in
testimonials as a part of all of the
different ways that i ask for feedback
maybe i need written ones maybe i
haven't updated or refreshed my
testimonials online in years maybe i
never asked for recommendations on
linkedin so i would start there in a
very tactical sense and then i would go
right through this checklist and study
of going then it's ask yourself
do you have the expertise that the
market is asking for and so what they're
saying is like are you paid to speak and
consult on these things so are you
signing up for all the different trade
shows or conferences or seminars of
going hey if i want to be seen as this
credible expert in this space then i
need to be outside of just my website or
my social media or my podcast and how am
i getting myself out there into these
other platforms and doing podcast
interviews would count in that arena and
then i would follow the list again and
go to number three and i would say now i
need to look at my website and go is
that representative of who i am
what i want to be known for and my
audience both visually and in writing
so what does my copy say
and then does this look feel tone does
that really fit who i am today and where
i want to be and more importantly would
this appeal to my core target audience
because a lot of times we build our
websites for ourselves
not for our audiences and those are
really for your audience unless you just
like to go to your own website every day
and so it's like it's really getting
clear on some of those things on a very
tactical standpoint but those should
stem from knowing very clearly what do
you want to be known for
in your market or quite honestly just in
life like what do you want when you die
when you're no longer here what do you
want people to say about you what do you
want to be known for when you're no
longer here
powerful questions um
a couple action items think media
podcast that i think we could really
apply from this uh podcast is uh
take some time even right now before you
jump to the next thing and reflect on
those questions what do you need what do
you want to be
known for
and go as deep as possible and again if
you want some help um a couple things
check out the show notes get the free
study so that'll be linked up across
platforms uh if you're listening to this
on audio uh maybe uh tell siri to uh or
or google assistant hey remind me when i
get home from work today to go back to
this youtube video or this podcast on
desktop to download the study and to
really unpack some of those details so
that link's in the show notes and then
also if you're like man i really want
some more guidance check out
freebrandcall.com forward slash think
and you could jump on with brand
builders and they could help you with
that cass recently did one of those free
calls and actually um you're gonna get a
lot of free insight a lot of uh guidance
and then you also hear if you want to
work with brand builders or not uh aj
and rory um i've been getting to know aj
just now i've known rory for a couple
years i missed aj when we were recently
in nashville at vaden headquarters
and uh just world-class humans and
they've built a world-class team that
really has a methodology a proprietary
process to help you get super clear on
your personal brand monetize your
personal brand even scale your personal
brand to the million or eight figure
mark and so they have done this concept
to completion and what i love about them
is they're not fluff uh they're not like
a lot of people in the industry who talk
big but have shallow depth but they have
uh decades of experience in the industry
now new york times best-selling authors
all kinds of impact that they've made
and they've really done this on a uh
on a prolific level so they've developed
systems that can really help you and if
that's right for you don't miss this
take advantage of free brandcall.com
forward slash think and then also if you
begin value of this today i really
encourage you to share this with
somebody maybe there's somebody who's
been asleep on personal branding that is
a mistake personal branding is the
future it's now is the time you might
feel like you're a little bit behind
you're not behind but you got to get
started right now um if you want to be
in a powerfully positioned place a year
from now three years from now five years
from now the best time to get started
really getting all of the these details
right and built is right now and you
will be stunned the leads the sales the
relationships the impact the business
the collaborations the business
partnerships the
the associations the networking the open
doors that will happen for you on the
other side of personal branding but it's
not going to happen by accident it's
going to happen because of really taking
action on the information on this today
so two things if you think of somebody
maybe share this just personally with
somebody text them let them know about
this episode on the think media podcast
um if you're catching the video version
drop your biggest aha moment in the
comments um and if you're on audio a
review really helps us on the podcast we
want to know if this is the type of
content that's really helping you in
terms of um
going further faster with your youtube
channel and your business aj vaden
you are an incredible person i am so sad
that you weren't there when i was
hanging out with rory last time i was in
nashville but there will be a time i got
to meet your son and uh one of them
and uh they're wild and awesome so
i have a one-year-old now he just turned
one sean bradley kennel
and um
so i'm excited for when we can connect
to the future but for those that want to
connect with you personally besides some
of the links and resources and of course
we'll post all your socials where could
people follow you and get more uh info
from you and follow you personally
instagram if you want me as a person if
you want me as a ceo linkedin is it
underscore it's aj underscore vaden both
places
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast today yeah it was awesome thank
you so much
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
[Music]
[Music]